باب للدبلوماسيه لا يزال مفتوحا على
مصراعيه امام التفاوض بشان احياء الاتفاق
النووي الايراني لعام 2015
وفق تقرير لرويترز
حاولت الاداره الامريكيه رغم التعنت
الايراني كما ذكر دبلوماسيون في واشنطن
وفشلت في احياء الاتفاق لكن الولايات
المتحده حلفاءها الاوروبيين يرفضون قطع
الامل
التفاؤل الغربي بشان الاتفاق يعكس خطوره
المقاربات البديله كما نواها دبلوماسيون
غربيون تحدثت اليهم رايترز المسؤولون في
العواصم الغربيه يشددون على انهم لا
يعتقدون ان هناك اي خطه للقيام بعمل عسكري
ضد ايران لان الضربه قد تعزز ببساطه اي
رغبه ايرانيه في الحصول على اسلحه النوويه
وتخاطر برد ايراني
ايران الان تقوم بتخصيب اليورانيوم وصولا
لنسبه 60 في محطتها النوويه فوردو متجاوزه
الى حد كبير عتبه الثلاثه في المئه فاصل
67 المحدده بموجب الاتفاق النووي لكن لا
تزال بعيده عن عتبه التسعين بالمائه
اللازمه لصنع قنبله ذريه وهو ما قال
دبلوماسيون انهم يعتبرونه خطا احمر حسب
روترز
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف غوريلا راى اخيرا الا خيار افضل من
خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه لضمان عدم
تطوير ايران لاسلحه النوويه حبل العقوبات
بات يخنق ايران ونظامها القمعي وابقى
تعبير دبلوماسيين غربيين
احتجاجات داخليه وعزه دوليه لكن المرجح في
المرحله الحاليه وفق تقرير رويترز ان هذا
لن يمنع ابقاء الدبلوماسيه حيه حتى اذا
ماتت خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه المتصله
بالاتفاق النووي لعام 2015